terminus à quelques mètres de là les
centrales du cimetière de toulon
c'est le bout du voyage pour une
vingtaine de femmes et d'hommes
des anonymes dont on sait seulement
qu'il venait d'afrique pour rejoindre
l'europe
des tons provisoire avec un numéro
d'identification si jamais un jour
quelqu'un venait réclamer les corps
depuis une quinzaine d'années on estime
qu'entre dix mille et 30 mille migrants
clandestins sont morts en tentant de
rejoindre l'europe victime de naufrage
de noyade et pour certains de meurtre
[Musique]
un film voyage vers l'enfer relate
l'assassinât de huit passagers
clandestins
toute ressemblance avec des personnages
ou des faits ayant existé n'est
absolument pas fortuite
ce film est inspiré d'une histoire vraie
la fiction est même tout à fait conforme
à la réalité
l'histoire commence mollement dans un
port du ghana où des dizaines de dockers
des charges des céréales
les personnages sont anonymes figurants
infatigable qui rejoue le même rôle les
jours dans bausch
sur les quais sans aucun doute la
plupart des hommes rêvent de traverser
la mer pour espérer une vie meilleure
en 1992 kingsley ofosu touché un dollar
par jour quand il décrocher un job sur
le port
il avait 21 ans c'est cette année là
qu'il est sorti de l'ombre
j'étais jeune que je pensais qu'en
europe on trouvait rapidement du travail
si on voulait étudier
j'aurais aimé le faire
sans trouver une école
en europe je pensais qu'on pouvait avoir
un diplôme et devenir quelqu'un
ça s'est pas passé comme ça pour moi
quand j'y pense ça a été tellement
douloureux
on est parti tous ensemble et ils ont
tous été tués
tous même mon frère
c'est trop dur je suis désolé je ne peux
pas parler de ça je ne veux pas me
rappeler de tout ça ça me fait trop mal
[Musique]
une passerelle des amis d'enfance bien
décidé à tenter la grande aventure et au
bout du quai un cargo en chargement
kingsley ofosu et c'est oui camarade
penser que le voyage allait durer deux
ou trois jours
[Musique]
le mc ruby est arrivé dans le port pour
nous c'était une chance
il partait en europe est pour ça que
nous sommes monté dedans on était
embauchés comme docker occasionnels
charger les sacs de cacao c'est en
faisant le chargement qu'on a réussi à
se cacher à l'intérieur
si vous n'étiez pas là je ne serais pas
venu ici
chaque fois que je vois un cargo mes
limites comme fait repenser à tout ça
à 21 ans kingsley croyait dur comme fer
à son projet étudié et passer un diplôme
d'ingénieur en europe avant de retourner
travailler au pays
sa femme allait accoucher il n'y avait
décidément pas d'avenir sur le port
[Applaudissements]
paris quartier latin
le dossier du mc ruby n'est pas encore
archives et il est même à portée de main
d' isabelle coutant-peyre l'avocate des
familles des victimes
le cas du m6 rugby ce n'est pas
seulement un crime crapuleux pour m
coûtant peyre cette histoire n'est pas
celle d'un équipage qui aurait perdu la
raison au point de commettre plusieurs
assassinats
y avait une nombreux problèmes de
passager clandestin sur cette ligne qui
donc partait du cameroun vers l'europe
et de rome vers le cameroun est donc un
certain nombre de problèmes et est
arrivé entraînant le limogeage de deux
commandants successifs lorsque les
passagers clandestins sont découverts
dans des navires accostant en europe la
police y mobilisent les navires retard
dans la livraison mettant en péril la
cargaison en l'occurrence dans cette
affaire c'était du cacao qui donc
pourrait en quelques jours il était
clair pour le commandant et l'équipage
que s'il y avait des passagers
clandestins seraient limogés donc ça
veut dire entraîné une décision de les
faire disparaître
les jeunes gens sont découverts
dépouillés de leurs dollars et puis
exécuté au fusil mitrailleur vie
ghanéens ont été précipités par dessus
bord seul kingsley a réussi à échapper
aux marins et à se cacher dans les cales
du bateau
[Musique]
durant trois jours kingsley se terrent
dans les plus profonds recoins du mc
ruby
[Musique]
au cours d'une escale au havre il arrive
à s'enfuir et dénonce l'équipage
ukrainien
le fait divers est à la une de tous les
journaux après douze heures de délibéré
dimanche à 6 heures du matin la cour
d'assises de rouen a rendu son verdict
les matelots les exécutants des crimes
ont été condamnés à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle le commandant et son second
ont connu un sort plus sévères la peine
maximale la perpétuité
durant le bronze pour certains
observateurs ce drame est d'abord celui
d'une misère noire brutalisé par une
autre misère
on a pris comme bouc émissaire parce que
je considère comme des pauvres books et
on n'est pas allé chercher les vraies
responsabilités
ces compagnies d'armement commerciales
qui ont des sociétés opaque qui ne
payent pas d'impôts et qui font la loi
en mer et deuxièmement les et à la
politique des états et s'aggravera parce
que je vois que maintenant c'est toute
l'europe qui se met qui s'installe comme
une forteresse
la législation s'est considérablement
durcie depuis septembre 2001 les porcs
sont très protégés et les clandestins
plus que jamais criminalisés
mais la pression s'exerce aussi sur les
professionnels de la mer
jean paul ii claire et membre de
l'association française des capitaines
de navire
témoin des grands bouleversements qui
ont changé l'image de son métier et à 30
ans les capitaines qui fréquentaient des
maires il y avait des mots de pippo y
avait un point d'honneur de se dérouter
pour pouvoir récupérer ces pauvres gens
qui fuyaient la misère dans leur pays et
les ramener dans des endroits où vous
pourrez vivre décemment et donc c'est
quand il arrivait en france les ses
capitaines là étaient considérés comme
des roues et les les boat people dont
ces immigrés clandestins se retrouvait
également considérés comme des héros on
a certains nos collègues qui ont été
décorés de la légion d'honneur pour ça
et aujourd'hui lé capitaine qui ramène
des clandestins ou qui ramène des boat
people qu'ils ont récupérés en mer sont
considérés comme des délinquants qui
sont accusés de dead à l'immigration
clandestine voilà
au ghana kingsley temps de redémarrer
une nouvelle vie
il est resté une dizaine d'années en
france pour étudier d'abord et puis
comme beaucoup de compagnons d infortune
il a travaillé dans une chaîne de
restauration rapide
ans
[Musique]
parfois dehors on reconnaît kingsley
mais pour les gamins de la plage
quelqu'un qui a tout perdu n'est pas un
héros les héros ici ce sont les
footballeurs qui reviennent au pays avec
des vêtements de marque et au volant de
grosses limousines
[Musique]
nous on veut partir à l'étranger pour
réussir notre vie
leblanc il peut être comme un diable se
maintient la tête sous l'eau
c'est toi qui es ton propre diable
personne ne t'a obligé à monter sur un
bateau pourquoi t'as pas pris l'avion
l'avion c'est cher
ouais c'est trop cher il faut un
passeport
c'est une question ça oui alors il faut
prendre quoi le bateau ou l'avion
le bateau c'est gratuit il n'y a pas
besoin de billet ouais ça coûte rien
ouais d'accord mais vous avez entendu
son parti neuf et il y en a huit qui ont
été tuées quand même mais qu'est ce
qu'ils font là ces bateaux si c'est pas
pour monter dessus
le bâton n'est pas là pour embarquer des
gens est alors pourquoi faire c'est pour
les containers oui mais les contenait
repartent à vide on peut les remplir on
monte dedans et c'est gratuit
imaginez que vous êtes des juges
et on vous amène les marins qui nous ont
tiré dessus
ils ont frappés avec un marteau roddick
sont mordus ils ont tiré dessus ils ont
volé moi si j'étais le juge mais tu es
le juge alors ok si je suis le juge les
condamnerait à 400 entreprises
la perpétuité c'est pas assez 400 ans
c'est plusieurs vies
la perpétuité n'y a rien fait depuis le
mc ruby d'autres affaires similaires se
sont produites plus discrètement
en turquie au large de l'algérie ou en
galice
en 2004 no hysteria avait à peine
accosté dans le port de ribera au nord
de l'espagne qu'une brigade de police a
fait irruption sur le quai
la guardia civil agissaient dans le
cadre d'une plainte pour meurtre
le capitaine dénoncé par un marin avait
jeté au large de la mauritanie quatre
passagers clandestins qui s'étaient
noyés sous les yeux de l'équipage
le capitaine et certains de ses hommes
ont été emmenés au poste pour
interrogatoire
mais coup de théâtre le juge a décidé de
les remettre en liberté le crime avait
été reconnue mais ils avaient été commis
en dehors des eaux territoriales
je pense que les magistrats font pas
tous bien leur travail l'article 15
cette convention de genève dit
exactement ce sont des actes de violence
ou de détention commis pour des buts
personnels contre des personnes à bord
en un lieu ne relevant de la juridiction
d'aucun état c'est à dire donc les eaux
internationales
donc c'est parfaitement clair ces
articles 15 et l'article 19 de la
convention de genève sur la haute mer
prévoit que les états sont tous
compétente
alors les bateaux sont ils des
territoires à part des lieux d'impunité
les cas d'homicides sont certainement
rare mais cette question est légitime
encore faut-il qu'on nous réponde sur la
mer on nous conseille d'aller rendre
visite aux pilotes aux entrées et aux
sorties des ports ce sont eux qui font
les manoeuvres qui rencontre les
équipages et discutent avec les marins
parfois cela seul
jean philippe rigaud guide un pétrolier
indien à la sortie de fos-sur-mer
dans la confrérie des pilotes jean
philippe est un peu à part
beaucoup d'équipages commence à le
connaître
l'installation est correct
quand le pilote arrive sur la pilotine
qui débarque la manoeuvre est terminé il
est en sécurité il fait un petit signe
de la main aux commandants qui veut dire
bon mais ça y est la mer est à vous pour
y aller personnellement j'y rajoute une
une bénédiction pour le bateau je
profite de cet instant en plus villégier
pour tout seul sur ma pilotine dure une
petite prière et placer le bâton et son
équipage surtout sous la protection de
marie l'étoile de la mairie
jean philippe rigaud et diacres
guide spirituel et pilote de port
il s'attarde parfois à bord d'un cargo
pour célébrer un office religieux
à la sortie des chantiers ont fait appel
à lui pour baptiser un nouveau navire
dans les consciences ou parmi les marins
sa place est un véritable observatoire
les grecs disait il ya les vivants les
morts et ceux qui vont sur la mer et la
mer est un milieu comme la demande
particuliers ou les marelles sont entre
eux et où il ya un petit peu une
une impunité qui est qui paraît évidente
dû au fait qu on est en dehors du monde
en étant devant du monde marin qui est
sur son bateau il y avait des parties
c'est un temps de l'absence totale de sa
famille est obligé de s'organiser sans
lui et sans pouvoir prendre le conseil
est lui-même de son côté c'est que tout
ce qui se passe à bord peut rester et
reste extrêmement confidentielles et
reste dans un milieu confiné sur le
bateau le marin se retrouvent livrés à
sa propre conscience disons morale pour
employer un mot plus général et
donc c'est un lieu jeudi le bateau c'est
le bateau en mer mais c'est aussi le
bateau en escale à l'autre bout du monde
c'est le lieu de toutes les tentations
ce qui permet des comportements qui sont
très excessifs mais qui sont pas
forcément très excessifs sur le plan
négatif ils peuvent l'être sur le plan
positif les marins ne sont pas forcément
tous complices sur un bateau et que fort
heureusement
il ya des prises de conscience
et plus de conscience qui permettent ce
genre d'événements soit connu maintenant
si un équipage et tous complices et
arrive à ses fins avec des passes et un
destin il est bien évident que l'on ne
saurait jamais l'histoire du rugby on la
connaît pas ce qu'il a vu parce qu'il a
lu nations vivant
[Musique]
le seamen's club un lieu tranquille où
les équipages viens de téléphoner à
leurs familles boire un verre et voir
d'autres têtes
c'est le seul endroit à quai ou jean
philippe rigaud peut passer du temps
avec des marins
au seamen's club nos questions
reviennent une fois encore sur les
clandestins
tiberio un capitaine de la marine
marchande et le seul a accepté de nous
répondre
quand vous arrivez au port c'est pas de
chance si vous avez des clandestins à
bord par exemple vous débarquez en
amérique alors là c'est un vrai problème
d'avoir des clandestins qu'est ce que
vous faites
vous ne pouvez pas voyagé avec eux ils
sont indésirables partout
le prochain port ne voudra pas les
débarquer
vous êtes obligés de les garder avec
vous
alors qu'est ce que vous faites
une fois il s'est passé quelque chose
dont je suis romain j'ai entendu
d'autres roumain qui c'était arrivé
il y a deux ans on donne un porte
containers naviguer vers le canada ils
ont trouvé des clandestins ils les ont
balancés aloès
je peux comprendre la raison bien sûr je
n'approuve pas mais je comprends les
capitaines
les problèmes avec les compagnies sont
tellement énormes pour le bateau
l'équipage
une fois que vous arrivez au port avec
des clandestins
on ne savait rien sur leur pays
d'origine leur langue parce qu'ils ne
parlent pas
il ya des problèmes immenses
alors peut-être car ça peut arriver
capitaine choisi ce moyen
de les jeter à l'eau
ça peut arriver
[Musique]
dans sa semaine sans travail kingsley le
rescapé pris tous les dimanches
la petite église du quartier accueille
sans relâche la même prière que les
décisions de justice soient respectés
toutes les décisions de justice
oui j'en ai assez d'attendre depuis 16
ans
je n'ai rien demandé mais tout le monde
sait combien j'ai souffert
laissez moi vous raconter une chose
l'équipage du mc rugby m'a volé l'argent
que j'avais sur moi lorsqu'ils m'ont
découvert 1600 $ qu'ils ne m'ont pas
rendu
aujourd'hui 16 ans plus tard je n'ai
même pas reçu l'équivalent de cette
somme en dommages et intérêts j'en ai
besoin
pourtant la cour exigé que me soient
verser des dommages et intérêts moi tout
ce que je veux c'est qu'on me rende au
moins l'argent qui m'a été volé
waouh
chaque année de plus en plus d'ombré
disparaît sur la route de l'europe
depuis la sphère du mc ruby kingsley
leur a donné un nom et un visage
à part ça rien n'a changé
[Musique]